uh what hold on i'll call you back
yes
yes
yes
hello
yes you called me yes can i help you
um
buddy you got to speak up you can't take
can you can you open your mouth
what's up hey uh are you
are you silver i can't hear you man can
you are you five are you hiding from
your mom speak up
um are you i'm sorry is your first
language
english
hello yeah i'm here can you hear me
yeah okay okay first off
can i help you what is it you want
are you a youtuber no i'm not a youtuber
i'm a trovo guy what's up dog
but but wait what what's up homie
why are you hanging up i go for
youtubers
but okay yes yes i am a youtuber why are
you calling
uh uh are you hearing my email your what
i'm sorry
your email my gmail
yeah yeah what did you email what did
you email
dr phil about what the doc i'm sorry you
email
you mowed me about dr phil yeah
hold on a second let me i'm gonna look
at my email right now hold on a second
let's see
this is tyrese yeah
okay yeah i got i got you sent me a
bunch of emails about dr phil
yeah about dr phil being a a predator
uh yeah and let me guess you found you
found some old videos that have the
number and you decided to call
uh yeah was that a good idea you think
you think that was a good idea
not um i'm still a little young
how old are you 15 you're 15. okay
first why aren't you in school is it
spring break
yeah oh okay so it's spring break and
you send me the doc
what made you send you the the dr phil
stuff
hey you know terrible things dr phil's
done yeah i mean i've seen a show it's
pretty terrible
no i talk about the the the camps
wait so dr phil has concentration camps
yeah um um sending kids to a camp
program so i'm oh so let me ask you a
question
were you sent were you were you sent to
one of these scared straight camps
no so then why are you so
why are you so worried about dr phil
he hung up on me
i'm sorry the person
[Music]
that was weird that was a weird one
it shows a [ __ ] tornado of a mess
jj what's going on today hello is this
the youtuber
[Laughter]
is this the youtuber
what the [ __ ] was that dude i have no
[ __ ] idea that was the weirdest thing
in the world
yo are you a youtuber are you a youtuber
you bumped frozen
for are you a youtuber well now listen
let me tell you something i do not
regret bumping frozen for anything
okay you should have bumped frozen five
minutes before that because he actually
kind of like put it into there for a
second are you okay yeah no no
i'm not okay there's a lot going on
[ __ ] i'm worried dustin's getting
catfished
all right so let's start with that
[ __ ] number two
frozen said to me stupid parody songs
and some kid is calling me about dr phil
having concentration camps
today's show is off the [ __ ] rails
dude it's off the rails
i don't know what to do to you like i
how do i help you with this
there's literally nothing you can't look
you know what you wanna now that you're
wrong you just wanna do the adrostia
stuff we're gonna do it anyway today
so we [ __ ] might as well you know
i am i am [ __ ] losing my mind today
what is
happening
holy [ __ ] did you get your package yet
or not yet
oh man my mail don't run till [ __ ]
late man
oh well you're good you're getting two
you're getting two packages remember
getting two packages yes one two
packages
royce yes am i gonna wanna murder one of
the packages
i think you're gonna like it i'm gonna
like it i think i think you're gonna
like him
like royce all right i'm not even the
[ __ ] second person to threaten to
murder something on your show this week
no you're not but you will be the third
yeah i i am uh i'm gonna tell you i'm
not gonna open it i'm gonna be a good
boy and i'm gonna call in tomorrow and
open this on airplanes
i can't wait i will murder
if it if it's what i think it is what
are you i'm gonna be headed what do you
think it is
i don't even understand i'm gonna behead
it what do you think what do you think
it is
like an isis video what what what do you
what do you think it is
okay i don't know what the one is but
the other one of them is a puppet you
need to relax
you need to relax jj you need to relax
i don't know why you're making such a
big deal out of this
i hope you send that one okay so i can
feel really good
i would never send dr nosenstein i would
never i don't trust you with him
you need a [ __ ] gum damn jj
you're making this weird